Transcriber: Ouaad Abdelkebir
المدقّق: Arwa Mohamed
(هتاف)
أهلا, كيف حالكم؟
هذه الصورة عندما فزت بالبطولة الأفريقية
للمرة الثالثة.
و كانت تعتبر من أهم
وأحلى البطولات بالنسبة إلى.
و هذه عندما كنت في دورة الألعاب الأولمبية
لطوكيو سنة 2021.
كانت مشاركتي الثالثة في الأولمبيات.
وفي ذلك الوقت, وصلت للدور اثنين وثلاثين.
وتعتبر أفضل نتيجة لأي بنت مصرية وأفريقية
في تاريخ الأولمبيات في كرة الطاولة.
الحمد لله.
وهذه بعد ما تم اختياري
من ضمن أكثر ثلاثين شخصية مؤثرة
تحت سن الثلاثين لمجلة فوربس للشرق الأوسط.
طبعا تعتبر حدث كبير بالنسبة إلي أيضا.
[فيديو]
في هذا الفيديو كنت أستلم الجائزة
في حفلة فوربس.
هي شخص مميز جدا.
لاعبة كرة  طاولة.
فازت بأول دورة أفريقية لها في 2011.
قبل أن تحصل على 7 ألقاب متتالية.
من 2014 ل 2020.
سيداتي وسادتي,
رحبوا بدينا مشرف.
الحمد لله أنا في كل هذه  اللحظات
كنت فرحة جدا.
وكانت كلها لحظات سعيدة جدا بالنسبة لي.
لكن الحقيقة أن وراء كل لحظة،  كانت
هناك لحظات أخرى صعبة جدا ومختلفة.
ناس كثيرة تظن أن عمل إنجاز
أو شيء جميل يكون سهل.
طبعا فالحقيقة
الطريق سيكون ممتلئ بتحديات ..
يجب على الشخص أن يتخطاها
ليتمكن من  الوصول للبطولة أو إنجاز كبير.
الناس يرون اللقطة الأخيرة فقط.
لا يرون الصورة الكاملة.
اليوم
أنا أريد أن أرتب التحديات هذه
واللحظات الصعبة لثلاثة أقسام أساسية.
أولهم هي التضحيات التي يلزم فعلها
للوصول لشيء جيد.
ثانيهم هي أن  على الشخص الخروج
من دائرة راحته.
وثالثهم هي كيفية تعامل الشخص مع الخسارة
و اللحظات الصعبة بعد الخسارة.
أول شيء سأتكلم عنه هو التضحيات.
بدأت  رحلتي مع الرياضة  عنما كنت
في السابعة من عمري تقريبًا،
وبعدها أصبح  لدي مواعيد تمارين معينة
ويجب طبعا أن ألتزم بها.
كنت أيضا مهتمة جدا بالجانب الدراسي.
و كانت رغبة أهلي أن أكون مجتهدة في دراستي
وأن أهتم بالمدرسة والرياضة معا.
حتى أستطيع أن أوفق
بين الدراسة والرياضة مع بعض،
كان يجب علي أن أضحي بأمر ثالث.
وهو وقت الترفيه.
مثلا، أنا أخرج  للترفيه  أٌقل من أصدقائي.
عطلاتي أقل ، وأسافر أقل، الذهاب للبحر،
أشياء مثل ذلك.
حتى بعد ما كبرت قليلا ودخلت الجامعة.
كنت أحيانا أضطر أن
أحمل كتبي المدرسية معي في الطيارة...
أدرس أثناء البطولة.
فالموضوع لم يكن سهل أبدا بالنسبة لي.
لكن في النهاية عندما  يحقق الشخص  أهدافه..
يحس أن تضحيته آتت أكلها .
وأن  الا مر كان يستحق التضحية .
ثاني شيء هو الخروج من دائرة راحتك.
أفضل الأمثلة على ذلك هي معسكرات الصين .
لمن يعرف, يهيمن  الصينيين
على هذه الرياضة .
كما تشاهدون في هذا الترتيب العالمي،
أول أربعة [صينيين].
هم قادرين أن يكونوا أول خمسين لو أرادوا
لأنهم الأحسن في رياضة كرة الطاولة.
فبالتالي أنا قررت أن أفضل مكان
أذهب لمعسكراته هو الصين.
وهذا ليس بأمر سهل لأن
أولًا: الصين بلد بعيد عنا
بالإضافة هم ناس مختلفة جدا عنا
وثقافتهم مختلفة.
ولا يتحدثون  اللغة الإنجليزية.
فالمكوث هناك أمر صعب للغاية حقًا،
بالإضافة  أن تمارينهم شديدة  للغاية،
غير سهلة على الإطلاق،
يتدربون طوال اليوم تقريبا.
فبالنسبة لي كان من الأسهل أن أبقى في مصر..
أتدرب في بلدي وأبقى مع عائلتي في البيت،
و أتدرب مع ناس أعرفهم
سواء في النادي أو في المنتخب،
لكن اخترت أن أفعل هذا الشيء
حتى لو لم يكن  الأمر مريح لي،
لكي في النهاية تكون النتيجة أفضل.
وطبعا الحمد لله ..
معسكرات الصين كانت سبب كبير
في نتائجي الجيدة.
ثالث شيء هو الخسارات.
و كيف للشخص أن يتعامل مع الخسارة ،
واللحظات الصعبة التي تتبعها.
كما تعلمون طبعًا،  الرياضة
فيها المكسب و الخسارة .
لا يمكنك الفوز طوال الوقت.
مثل الحياة بالضبط .
الحياة فيها تقلبات.
لكن أنا أرى أن الذي يفرق شخص عن الأخر...
هو كيفية تعامله في الأوقات الصعبة
و كيفية تعامله مع الخسارة.
هل سيقرر أنها تكون دائمة ، ويستسلم؟
أو يختار أنها تكون مؤقتة ويحاول أن
يغيرها ويغيرها من خسارة لمكسب،
بالحديث عن نفسي، في حياتي المهنية
أستطيع أن أقول ..
الحمد لله، أكتر الخسائر صعوبة
بالنسبة لي
كانت بعد ذلك سبب في أكبر إنجازاتي.
مثلا ..
في سنة 2021 خسرت بطولة أفريقيا ..
و بعدها بكم شهر في مايو 2022 ..
خسرت كأس أفريقيا.
وهذا كان بعد ستة أو سبع سنين متتالية ..
فزت في كل المسابقات الأفريقية
التي شاركت فيها الحمد لله.
في ذلك  الوقت كانت تلك الخسارة صعبة جدا ..
ليس بالأمر السهل،
اعتياد  الشخص على الفوز  ثم يخسر.
يقاسي الضغوطات، و يبد أ الناس بالحكم عليه.
ويسأله الناس: ماذا حصل؟
طبعا ليس بموقف سهل.
لكن في ذلك الوقت..
الحمد لله ، طبعا  بمساعدة أهلي ..
الذين قاموا بتشجيعي، لكي أن أكمل التدريب
وأن لا أتوقف،
بالإضافة كان عندي تحفيز عالي جدا.
وهذه تعتبر من ضمن المزايا
التي يمكن استغلالها عندما يخسر،
تعطي الخسارة  الحافز للشخص  لتحسين  أداؤه،
فبالتالي كنت متحمسة أن أكمل تدريب
وأتعب وأعمل على  تطوير نفسي.
فالحمد لله بعدها بأربعة أشهر فقط ..
فزت في بطولة أفريقيا في سبتمبر 2022.
وكان هذا في الصورة التي عرضتها في البداية.
أستطيع أن أقول أن تلك الخسارة
كانت نعمة من عند ربنا لي،
وكانت سبب لإنجاز مهم لي.
بالإضافة في نفس الفترة الحمد لله
فزت أصعب مباراتين،
فتاة من تايبيه الصينية،
وفتاة من هونغ كونغ،
وهاتان الفتاتان لم أتغلب عليهن من قبل.
بالعلم أنني كنت أبلغ من العمر 15 سنة
وأول مرة فزت ضدهم كانت..
بعد الفترة التي مررت بالخسارة فيها .
كما قلت لكم ، يمكن أن تكون الخسارة
فعلا نعمة من عند ربنا .
وبعدها تأتي إنجازات كثيرة.
في الختام،
أريد أن أقول لكل شخص
إذا كنتم تمرون بوقت صعب ..
وأيا كانت مهنتكم،
إذا كنتم تواجهون تحديات كبيرة في مهنتكم ،
وتشعرون فعلًا  بصعوبة الوقت،
كن على يقين أنه، إن شاء الله
بالاجتهاد في الطريق الصحيح وبالصبر،
إن شاء الله،
ستقابل إنجازات جميلة كثيرة تتحقق.
وتذكروا أن الطرق الصعبة دائما،
تؤدي إلي وجهات جميلة.
شكرا.
(تصفيق وهتافات)